i just had an idea two three four
[Applause]
yeah i really gotta stop trying that it
never works this better be good
holy moses what happened to you i have
not slept and since i last saw you many
hours
plus i think i'm hallucinating because
pretty sure i just heard your biceps
mocking me
no that's possible my biceps mock a lot
of people
good to know so i rewatched the
interrogation
and get this sophia wasn't lying about
anything
she doesn't know who killed nate dexter
but she does know something
way better come with me
jay people normally move after they say
that
oh yeah i fell asleep for a second sorry
come with me
[Music]
okay ah you all ready for this you know
what i'm saying
terry jeffords allow me to introduce to
you
our murder victim the not dead
nate dexter what the hell is going on
right sophia wasn't lying i was just not
asking the right questions
she hadn't seen her husband in eight
years but she was positive there's no
way that he killed dexter
that's when it occurred to me no one
killed him
hey nate just talking about how you're
alive yeah i'm alive
but whose melted torso did we find
sofia's husband yes sophia and dexter
were having an affair
husband found out nate killed him now
i'm telling my friend about how you
killed that guy
it was for love cool motive still murder
also you remember that severed finger
check this out hey nate show us your
hands please
oh right cut it off himself
how screwed up is that anyway i asked
all my cis if they had dealings with a
nine-fingered man
unsolvable case solved
so do you recognize any of these men i
was hiding in the bathroom stall so i
didn't see his face
but i heard him he was singing along to
the music at the bar do you remember
what he was singing i think it was that
song
i want it that way backstreet boys i'm
familiar okay
number one could you please sing the
opening to i want it that way really
okay you are
my fire
number two keep it going the one desire
number three believe when
i say number four i
wanted that away
tell me why ain't nothing but a
heartache tell me why
ain't
[Applause]
literal chills it was number five number
five killed my brother oh my god i
forgot about that part
that's weird police tape's already gone
oh yeah major crimes released the scene
yesterday but i'm sure they haven't had
time to clean up the evidence
oh man they emptied the place out
nothing left in here i can't believe
this is how it ends
yeah is it weird that i missed the smell
wait a minute do you hear that i've
spent 600 hours in this room and i have
never heard that sound it's because the
air conditioning's never been turned on
it's coming from that vent
[Music]
i don't see anything wait there's a bend
oh my god there's food and water in here
rosa we never saw the killer leave this
apartment because he never left
he couldn't have survived in there for
months that's insane he wasn't back
there for months he just waited for the
body to be discovered and then snuck out
sometime after that so this place was
crawling with cops which is exactly what
he wanted he snuck out dressed like a
cop even if he had a uniform somebody
would have recognized him not if his
face was covered by a hazmat suit the
csi guys
franco said he had 14 texts but didn't
you count 15. i did count 15. my math
was right
second mrs skanga she was my algebra 2
teacher she threw a protractor in my
head she sucks she
sucked actually she was very sweet she
believed in me oh yeah
here's the security footage it's rated g
for gonna get
got less is more franco play the tape
okay so there's us arriving oh man is
that how i walk
yes should i change how i walk yes all
right wait go back
jake we don't have time to fix your walk
it's gonna take a lot of work and we're
very busy
no look look at this guy all the other
techs are wearing booties but he's not
hold okay
where's the footage from the bodega
across the street
we have that that is so crazy we are
under surveillance at all times
i'm sure it's fine and it won't backfire
and ruin society zoom in on his face
that man's not csi no franco but he is
about to say
cs bye
spec jake respect
rosa you know what it's time for i do
jake and rosa's final impressions
client's a hitman who snuck into the
apartment during a party several nights
earlier hid
in the vent for three days then emerged
and murdered adam's jake he then spilled
bags of blood that he stole from a blood
bank all over the floor and turned on
the victim's vacuum cleaner to make the
crime scene as messy as possible rosa
messi's seen meant there be extra crime
text allowing your client to sneak out
in a hazmat suit which records show he
bought online two weeks before the crime
was committed
my only question is who was behind all
this i was hired by a chicken farmer
okay dopeness taking a late hit here but
we still got you see you at the
sentencing piece and we're out
so we will be filing a wrongful rest
suit against the nypd
and when i win i'm gonna buy club torque
put a statue of jake peralta right in
the middle
of dance floor first off that's a
terrible threat i would love to have a
statue of myself in the middle of a
dance club
second do me a favor take a look at this
picture and tell me what you see
you and regis philbin awesome right
surprisingly down to earth guy and
definitely not the picture i meant to
show you
but take a look at this that's right
it's you and your old cellmate marcus
cole
and here he is again outside the jewelry
store
the two of you planned this together in
prison you taught him your ammo he
pulled off the robbery
you got yourself an alibi and you split
the loot oh man i can't believe he
caught us
of course he did peralta is the best oh
thanks reg that's enough yeah i got to
work on my regis anyway see you in jail
whitman i don't know why you insisted on
eating here gina it seems like your
average greasy spoon heard me did one of
you order the hog plate
of justice peralta what are you doing
here saving new york city from a
maniacal um excuse me are those my eggs
kind of
interrupted an incredible moment but
here take that
no no we can't be seen together gina did
you know about this
um tricking me was the only way i could
get you to talk to him
plus you know i heart intrigue sir take
a look at these photos
none of the victims had any alcohol in
their apartments not even a dusty bottle
you want to know why
because they were all sober they all
attended 12-step programs
none of them the same one but they all
have the same leader a
creep with a record of torturing animals
i'm talking
dogs i found you long slayer
i never do this but i kind of ordered
rye
ma'am i'm not a waiter okay trying to
blow my friend's mind over here could
someone get this lunatic some rat
his name is james dylan borden and he
works the night shift at
creepapalooza the mannequin factory in
red hook
i'll pick you up at eight i told you not
to lie what were you thinking
i thought it would work and i wanted to
be the one that got him is this
about your ego are you that desperate
for everyone to know how great you are
it's not about everyone
okay it's just i wanted you to know
oh my god
i got it he's not answering any
questions that's okay i have no
questions that's right
i'm about to monologue son better make
it quick you only got eight minutes all
right then let me paint you a picture
i'm phillip
a successful periodontist that's become
addicted to diazepam a sedative i take
because i'm junkie scum also for real
addiction is a disease that would be
super empathetic if you hadn't murdered
a man what is the point of this i'll get
there
so one day i'm working late when my boss
robert surprises me he found out i was
stealing meds again jackie scum also
again not your fault there's a major
genetic component to addiction he says
he's gonna file a police report
i could lose my license we fight and
something in me just snaps so i grab the
first thing i can find
and i hit him with it you still have no
murder weapon i do now
here's a pic i found on yelp of the
surgical suite six months ago and here's
a shot that our crime scene photographer
took up the same room two weeks after
the murder notice any differences we're
not answering that that's all right i
can just tell you myself the yelp shot
has six of these heavy-looking glass
awards from the brooklyn periodontics
society in the background whereas this
shot only has five what happened to
number six you murdered robert with him
you lost all control and you bludgeoned
him to death there must have been blood
everywhere but you got lucky
you were in the surgical suite it can be
sterilized you never would have gotten
away with it in your carpeted office
that's not what happened don't say
anything more philly and your office
manager would have heard all of the
screaming but she was at her grandson's
play
lucky again you're wrong you put
robert's body into a wheelchair and
shoved it in the elevator it's a miracle
there wasn't blood everywhere that's not
true now you're in the garage with a
corpse you panicked and left your phone
in your office and you don't have your
car keys but roberts are in his pocket
so you put him in his car
and you take off no you can't believe
what you've done no phil you're
flustered you have no gps so you just
start driving no phillip next thing you
know you're in the pine barrens and it
hits you your uncle's cabin he has a
place there you're the luckiest son of a
woman
yes it was you got lucky at every turn
no i knew exactly where i was driving
i left my phone in the office on purpose
i was in a surgical suite by design and
i didn't use some glass award that any
idiot would clearly see was missing
i made a rod out of a special dental
polymer killed him with it then melted
it back down
it's already in a patient's mouth son
oh damn oh damn oh
damn and that is 3-0 dams
oh damn
you